nous garderons en effet la grandeur de l'Amérique je
la garderai si grande mieux que jamais
nous allons la garder meilleure que jamais
et c'est pourquoi ce soir je me tiens
devant vous pour lancer officiellement ma
campagne pour un second mandat en tant que président
des États-Unis  États-Unis, je suis officiellement
candidat à la présidence des
États-Unis et nous allons rendre notre
pays encore plus grand, nous avons traversé la
plus grande chasse aux sorcières de l'histoire politique,
la seule collusion a été commise par les
démocrates, les faux médias d'information et leurs
agents et les personnes qui  a financé le
faux dossier tordu Hillary Clinton
et le DNC
Hilary Clinton est la personne la plus corrompue
à s'être présentée à la présidence
[Applaudissements]
nous pensons que notre pays devrait être un
sanctuaire pour les citoyens respectueux des lois et non
pour les étrangers criminels lorsque le Mexique envoie
son peuple ils '  ils n'envoient pas de leur
mieux ils ne vous envoient pas ils ne
vous envoient pas ils envoient des gens qui
ont beaucoup de problèmes et ils
amènent ces problèmes avec nous ils
apportent de la drogue ils apportent le crime
ils sont des violeurs  pouvez-vous imaginer ces
caravanes sans avoir les barrières et
les murs que nous avons déjà mis en place et qui
sont en place ce pays serait un gâchis comme
vous ne le croiriez pas
donc le mur avance il
avance rapidement c'est beau
j'ai changé le design  c'est plus fort, plus grand,
mieux et moins cher nous devons
construire un mur les murs fonctionnent il suffit de demander à Israël les
murs fonctionnent ils fonctionnent Je ne veux pas dire les
petits murs Je ne veux pas dire les petits murs
Je veux dire ces
murs je veux dire Trump  murs comme vous le
savez, vous avez peut-être lu quelques
choses sur la Chine
J'ai parlé au président Xi formidable
président un grand dirigeant de la Chine
Je lui ai longuement parlé ce matin
et nous verrons ce qui se passera
accord et un
accord équitable ou nous n'allons pas avoir d'accord du
tout et ça va aussi et j'aime la Chine
alors mon locataire ils achètent des condos tout le
temps ils vont bien mais vous savez ce qu'ils
sont un manipulateur de devises et
nous '  nous allons appliquer des tarifs douaniers à tout
pays qui dévalue sa monnaie pour
obtenir un avantage injuste sur les
États-Unis rendons l'Amérique encore plus grande
maintenant nous voulons tous recommencer à rendre
l'Amérique forte et grande encore
vous êtes prêt Gardez l'Amérique géniale
vous